she had wanted to make this for a long
time and we'd actually six years ago
talked about it extensively she optioned
that she wrote thee she wrote it as a
feature film and then realized it was
too there was too much to fit in
so then rewrote it as a six-part series
and then had several life emergencies
that slowed it down so we just kept
holding it for her and then it came the
time when she could actually do it so
two two stories of weird delays came
together in 2017 just in time for the
election of Donald Trump
I did not rig that it was to make you
feel better that's that's what you're
really asking you're asking whether I
rigged the election no I did not rigged
it but it reframed these stories in a
different way for the viewers they were
already underway they were already
written they were already what they were
and Handmaid's Tale was halfway through
filming and I think alias grace it
pretty much wrapped by that time yeah
yeah but just about there yeah so that
is just a tale of strange uncanny eerie
and weird coincidences so what was it
like to follow up questions to that
was it about Sarah that impressed you
it's all back you can sink a while it's
not obvious first of all she was devoted
to the book and that's what you want and
somebody who's going to make it into
something second she's very smart third
I had of course viewed her other work I
had watched her career evolved with much
interest and forth my friend Rick
Salutin would have killed me if I hadn't
took so long or you have you've been
working on this for a long time are you
glad that you sort of were like I've
seen the first three episodes are
amazing I'm like just are you glad that
you sort of had we're forced to sort of
wait until now and the production values
and stuff like that
yeah I am for all kinds of reasons one
of the reasons is even when I first was
writing this even though we were already
in the golden age of television there
wasn't an appetite for limited series
yet the idea of the miniseries still
hadn't really come back in any
meaningful way so I remember when I was
first trying to set this up talking to
my agents and them saying you know if
you wanted this to be an ongoing series
there'd be 80 places we could pitch
right now but there's almost nowhere
who's interested in doing six parts by
the time we had the meeting with Netflix
miniseries is very much what people were
interested in so if this had happened
with any other timing I don't think I
would have been able to make it the six
hours that it needed to be with the
budget it needed to be I had tried to
make it as a feature and I had to
eliminate almost all of the things I
loved about the novel in order to do
that so it was really important to me
that this know I'll be able to this this
story be able to breathe out and also
include so much of the context and the
political history and details of the
society that we're in the novel that I'd
loved so much so speaking of the novel
Sarah as grace
amazing what makes her the perfect grace
she can do so much with so little I mean
the tiniest shift in her face conveys so
much she's deeply intelligent she she is
a complex person and I think that comes
through in her work she's old and young
at the same time she's I really we saw a
lot of people for grace I don't think
there's anyone else who could have done
it in this way and I think there's been
many actresses over the years who've
been attached to play that part Cate
Blanchet was attached for a while Keira
Knightley was attached for a while there
are a lot of actresses who have wanted
to play this part of the earth I
actually don't think any of them would
have been able to do it the way that
Sarah did